[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
how many people here actually know about
in flux DB as a project okay
like Taff maybe so in flux DB is an open
source time series database that I
started about three and a half years ago
so this talk is about the storage engine
that we made obviously and some of the
other things that we used a long way and
there's also some material at the end
about a new piece of the storage engine
that we're testing out now that will be
it's in the nightly builds now and it
will be dropping as a default feature in
the near future so the storage engine of
the database is basically kind of two
storage engines in one the database is
like two databases in one the first is a
time series database which basically
just it has you know a time series and a
collection of values and time stamps in
time sorted order right and we do
compression and stuff like that on on
the time series and then there is an
inverted index now normally when you
think about an inverted index you think
about search databases right like they
map terms to document IDs and and use an
inverted index to quickly look up what
documents match which search terms in
our case we're matching time series
metadata with the time series that we
have so before I get into the actual
storage engine I need to introduce kind
of like how we structure data inside of
influx so obviously everything is
indexed by time and the series that it
is so within the database we also have
this concept of shards which are
basically just blocks of time so in this
example we have one shard for each day
now all the time series data for a given
day will exist in that one shard so that
makes it efficient later on to drop old
data if we want to so this is what
influx TVs data looks like so this is
our line protocol which is basically
just a text protocol for writing data
into the database
so first we have a measurement name it's
a string then we have tags with your key
value pairs where the values or strings
and then we have fields key value pairs
where the values are different value
types that we support and finally we
have a timestamp now that looks like a
second level second precision epoch but
we actually store time stamps at the
nanosecond scale then a lot of people
have expressed a surprise or shock that
we support nanosecond scale time stamps
because you wouldn't think that you
would need that but we actually have a
number of users and customers that use
nanosecond scale time stamps so think
people in high-frequency trading firms
or people doing scientific research in
like quantum computing environments
those actually requiring nanosecond
precision time stamps to track that data
alright so looking at an example here so
each series and field map to a unique ID
so basically that's what we think of as
a series right we have the measurement
name the tag set and the actual field so
the series is basically just going to be
a time ordered collection of values so
you can look at it as like a time or a
collection of tuples right where you
have a time stamp and a value so there
we have that each one so so looking at
how to organize time series data in say
a key value store this is like one way
you could do it right you have the key
which is your ID and then a timestamp
and then you have a value so here we
have you know one value in series one
and one value in series two and that we
were insert a new value into series one
we just put it there in the key space so
the the important thing is that the key
space needs to be ordered you need to be
able to do a range scan over the key
space to get your data in you know time
series order so here's just inserting
more now there are a lot of storage
engines out there that have this model
right leveldb has got it LM TVs got it a
bunch of like key value stores that let
you do range scans through the key space
so the question is
why in the hell would we want to create
our news to our own storage engine right
this is a problem that is fiendishly
difficult I've heard people say like a
store a new database storage engine
takes like 10 years to mature like it
takes a long time to actually build it
to the throw bust and you can rely on it
so why in the hell would we want to do
that well first we used LSM trees so
specifically we use the leveldb which is
an embedded database it's a C++ library
that was written at Google and it's
what's called a log structured merge
tree now LSM trees are heavily optimized
for write throughput they're very very
fast with that they also do compression
and we tried so we for the first I don't
know like year and a half of the project
we used level DB at the underlying data
store and we also tried some of the
variants later on we tried hyper level
DB which is a fork of it we tried rocks
DB which is a fork of level DB that's
developed at Facebook when we first
started influx rocks actually didn't
exist so one problem with LSM tree is
deletes are very very expensive so when
you do a delete you actually write a
tombstone record to disk and then later
on when you query you have to resolve
the keys in the database with the
tombstones - that exists actually return
the real result and then later on a
compaction process will run that will
rewrite your SS tables to remove that
record right so basically to remove a
single record you end up rewriting a
bunch of other records which can get
expensive and one another problem we had
was as I mentioned we have we organize
our data into shards of time and what
how we did that was we created a new
level DB database for each block of time
and this wasn't a problem initially but
for users that had very very large
databases or very large spans of time
they would actually end up blowing out
the number of file handles open in the
process so we just run out of file
descriptors so we also tried a memory
memory
mapped copy-on-write B plus trees right
so LM DB is this the first version of
MongoDB was this there is a librarian
NGO called bolt DB which is the one we
used it was heavily inspired by LM DB so
copy-on-write B plus trees are pretty
cool they're they're good but the write
throughput really sucks on them they're
not optimized for write heavy workloads
what we found is that initially the
write throughput would be pretty good
and then as the database grew in size it
would get slower and slower and even
worse it would crush I ops on our disks
like you'd see I'd like I up spikes got
like 20,000 and all sorts of crazy stuff
and the one another thing that was kind
of a complete deal-breaker for us was
with bolt it would size the memory map
file and have the size every time it
started to overgrow that it would over
grow that size it would double the size
of the file right so it's not that big
of a deal when you grow when you're
growing from 256 megabytes to 512
megabytes but when we were in the
gigabyte scales and and hundreds of
gigabytes it would just freeze the
entire database what resize that file
which sucks and then the other thing
that was also a deal-breaker for us is
there's no compression minute there's no
compression built into that storage
engine so you would have to layer it on
top and for the time series use case
compression is actually very very
important so none of the solutions that
we saw out there actually met our
requirements right we needed something
the supported high right throughput we
is something that had really good read
performance which is the weird thing
about time series it's like the worst
possible use case for databases because
not only do you have high write
throughput you also have high read
throughput from all the dashboarding
systems and monitoring systems and stuff
they're just pummeling the database with
range requests all the time we need
something with better compression so we
looked at different techniques for
compressing time series data and what we
found was that we could achieve better
compression than a generalized algorithm
like snap
so we wanted to optimize that we need
something where rights wouldn't block
reads and reads can't block writes we
would rather read stale data then to
have a read block the block writes
coming into the system and the other
thing about time series data is that
it's largely an append-only workload
you're not updating records right you're
just appending new data are you doing
backfill of historical data so and it's
always moving so if you do a read and
it's a little bit stale you're talking
about microseconds or milliseconds or
maybe seconds that weren't included in
the request so we also need to be able
to write multiple ranges simultaneously
so one of the use cases that we have
come up a lot is sensor data and in many
sensor data scenarios you have lagged
data collection right so they'll collect
locally and they'll transmit the data
like once an hour once every four hours
or once a day so we know that at any
given time there could be writes
happening in different time ranges in
the database that are all somewhat close
to now but could be off and something
that could support hot backups at the
time level DBA lovely I don't think
level DB at this point supports backups
hot backups either but Rox does so but
at the time we didn't have an option for
it and we need to have many databases
open in a single process without it
crashing things so about a year and a
half ago we set about to create our own
storage engine which we call the time
structured merge tree or TSM tree it's
heavily inspired by all some trees but
it's a little bit different so here are
the different components of the storage
engine we have a right ahead log we have
an in-memory cache and we have index
files that are read-only this is very
very similar to how LSM trees are
structured right
right ahead log same same concept in LSM
tree in level DB it's called mem tables
in level DB it's called SF tables right
but they're basically the same things
right so going through what it looks
like when we write data to the storage
we have often time series data coming in
we write it to the wall we write it to
in memory the in-memory data structure
that can be queried and then we send a
response back to the client at this
point because we know the right is
durable and it's immediately available
for reads and then periodically we'll do
flushes of this in memory index to what
we call TSM files which would basically
those SS table their files that are
indexed that have a specific structure
that are read-only files and we also
memory map those files so we can access
them like they're an array but more
importantly we let the operating system
handle caching for us right we let it
page stuff in and out of memory so that
we don't have to write all that logic
ourselves so we get a bunch of stuff for
free by memory mapping the files so
here's what a TSM file looks like we
have a header we have blocks of data we
have an index and then we have a footer
so the header looks like this you have
the magic the magic four bytes that tell
you what kind of file it is and then we
have a version the blocks look like this
right so we have collection of blocks we
have a CRC and then we have the actual
data where the data is compressed time
series data for a given series right and
and then if we have a new series will
have a new block and actually even for a
given series we don't compress all of
its data in one run which I'll talk
about in a second then we have an index
so we can see the key length the key
itself which is a string key right the
measurement name the tag set the field
we have the number of values that are in
the file
the min time in the max time and we use
that basically so that when a query
comes in looking for a specific time
range we can find which follows in and
where in the file it is quickly and then
finally we have a footer that just tells
us where the start of the index is so
basically when we have that memory map
file we know we look at the last four
bytes of the array we can jump to that
spot where
the indexes and we're able to do things
on the index as if it's like an
in-memory structure right so we can do
searches and stuff so here's what the
compressed blocks look like you have a
type which is the type of the of the
field we support in 64 float64 boolean's
and strings which is actually quite a
bit different from other time series
databases many other time series
databases only let you store numbers and
usually it's a specific kind of number
either a float 64 or an n64 and then we
have time stamps and values so this is
the part where I say we we we break
series data into blocks of things
because we we separate the time stamps
and values because we can achieve better
compression so by default we will encode
up to a thousand value timestamp pairs
into a single one of these blocks so if
a request comes in for a single value we
actually end up decoding a thousand
worth right so looking at the
compression the time stamps we encode
based on the precision and the deltas
between them right so we support
nanosecond level precision but just
because we support that doesn't mean we
need to represent all the lower order
bits if they're all zeroed out right so
in the best-case scenario we can use run
length encoding for our time stamps so
if you have a regular time series where
you're taking samples once every 10
seconds right
you only need second-level precision so
all you need to do is store the initial
starting timestamp and the Delta between
them and you know like okay so we have
we can just construct any timestamp in
the run from that information so the
okay case we use a compression technique
called simple 8b it's full from this
paper anima fit and index compression
using 64-bit words
so that's cases where it looks kind of
like a double delta encoding right so
times
stamps aren't fixed they aren't fixed
collection intervals that bucketed times
that could be variable right they could
have some jitter by a second or two or
microseconds or milliseconds so in the
worst cases we actually have to store
the raw value we have to store the full
n64 timestamp so that's that comes up in
situations where people are like using
nanosecond scale time stamps but the
distance between each timestamp is too
great to represent is alike a delta or
like the the cost of representing would
be more than just storing a raw
timestamp itself so for float64
compression we use a double delta
technique it's very similar to the
facebook gorilla paper so in to thin the
summer 2015 facebook published a paper
about gorilla which is their metric
system that they have in-house and it
used this this compression technique for
their flow values and they said that
they could compress data down to
depending on the shape of the data down
to about 1.1 bytes per they're using a
32-bit timestamps which is different
than us they're also interleaving
timestamps and values which we don't do
so we kind of changed it up a bit so
this guy Jamie and risky who's a pretty
well-known go developer wrote an
implementation of this after the paper
came out and we just kind of took that
forked it and actually made the
modifications that we needed for our use
case boolean czar bits
those are easy right in 64 we use double
Delta or zigzag encoding zigzags the
same as protobufs strings we just use
snappy we're thinking about adding
dictionary compression later but snappy
is good enough for now
so updates we can actually update values
it's not something we're optimized for
but basically if any value in the
database is keyed off of the measurement
name tags set field and nanosecond scale
timestamp right so you can only have one
value at any
you given series key and nanosecond
scale time stamp so if you write in
another value with that exact same
information it will take the place of
the one that exists so essentially we
resolved that at query time by
eliminating the older dupes and then
later on when the compaction process
runs it throws out the old value and
keeps the new value deletes this is very
similar to an LS m3 we write a tombstone
the compact the at query time we resolve
the tombstones with the data that we
read from the index in the in memory
index and then compactions later we'll
rewrite the PSM files and remove the
deleted data so compactions basically
what they do is they just combine
multiple TSM files into one larger TSM
file our goal with the compactions is to
put as many points from the same series
into a single file right so that they
have a run a contiguous run that way we
can do quick rain scans on the data and
do computations on it right
I mentioned points in 1k blocks we have
multiple levels of compaction right
where we favor the lower levels first
and then the larger levels later and the
other thing is as we're compacting data
we the the TSM files are in time order
they have time ranges in them so if
you're just writing now data right your
pending new data all the time those
older files will get to a point where
they get compacted and then they won't
get touched right we'll only be touching
the young generation of TSM files but
because we have this idea of shards
shards generally will go cold for writes
after some time so after a while we will
actually try to do a full compaction on
that shard which will look at all the
TSM files and try to optimize for the
best possible like combination all right
so now I'll talk a little bit about the
indexing scheme that we have
so this is to go through this walk to
look at this sample query just so we
understand like the the kind of scope of
the problem right so in this query we're
grabbing the 90th percentile value from
the CPU measurement for the last 12
hours only from hosts in the western
region and we want ten minute buckets
and we want a series for every single
host right now the question becomes how
do we map this metadata the measurement
am CPU hosts a region to the underlying
series so that we can perform this
computation and return a bunch of
individual time series backs so we use
an inverted index right so one would the
way to look at it like what we do right
now for the in memory index is we have
you know the series keys which is that
string which maps to unique ID and we
need to see what measurements have what
fields so we can map that later we need
to see for what hosts what values we
have write the tag key host and what
unique values for the region what
regions we have and then we need to keep
our posting lists right what IDs appear
under the CPU measurement what ideas
appear under each tag key value pair and
then later app when you're querying the
data you can do things like unions and
intersects to to find out what are the
list of series IDs that you need to work
with so index be one which is what's in
the current release right now which is
1.2 is in memory we load it on boot
right so we have all the underlying TSM
files when the database starts up it
looks at those files looks at the series
keys in each of those files and build
this in memory index and what that means
is one you're obviously memory
constrained right you can only have as
many unique series in your databases you
can actually keep in the in memory index
but you can also get to a stage where
you have slower boot times if you have
really high cardinality so you could
have a ton of memory but you know on a
system where you have
you know a few hundred gigabytes of
memory it takes a long time to boot that
up and read that much data into memory
right so our goal with index t2 was we
wanted something that is on disk and in
memory like a combination and really
like the key problem we were trying to
solve here is that we have a lot of use
cases where time series are ephemeral
right so if you're thinking about
tracking container metrics or individual
process metrics and you want the
container ID or the process ID to be in
a tag like those are ephemeral right you
could have the process running for a few
hours a few days and then it's going to
go away and you may query it later but
most likely it's not in your working set
it's not hot for queries or for writes
after it goes away so we want something
that would work for those kinds of
ephemeral series so we let's see like
last September we started creating
something we called we just called it
psi for time series index because we are
tired of trying to be creative with
naming so here's kind of what it looks
like right so new data comes in and we
have the index and we say ok here's the
time series metadata which is really
just that key itself right we check the
in memory index then we check the on
disk index do we already have it if we
do we don't need to do anything we don't
need to write it to disk we just
continue continue it on about our
business if we don't have it then we
need to write it to a right ahead log
right an append-only file and then
periodically that wall and write it to
an in-memory index and then periodically
that wall will get flushed out to disk
so this is very very similar to to TSM
to our to our other engine and then
there compactions that run in the
background to combine these index files
into larger and larger index files right
again just like TSM so here is what a
log entry looks like in
and are right ahead logs we have a flag
the reason there's a flag is because you
can do a deletion or an insertion of new
series metadata your measurement name
your tag key value pairs and it checks
um so the index file looks like this we
have a number of different blocks we
have blocked for what series exist in
the index what tags exist a tag key
value pairs and then what measurements
exists and then offsets for the
different locations of the blocks so
let's look a little bit at what the
series lock looks like so we have these
different like components in it right we
have different through these keys and
then we have an index and we've bunch
more serious keys and then another index
and then some other stuff now the reason
we have serious keys and then an index
and the more serious keys and then an
index is because we we don't we don't
want to have to read all the series keys
into memory at one time so by default we
we write out 65,000 series keys at a
time and these are always written in
sorted order so what that means is as
we're going through and compacting index
files we can actually do it in as a
streaming job right we can read multiple
index files merge them together and
write out the 65k series and more and
more and more and more right so we never
have to have more than 65,000 series
keys in memory to actually get it out to
disk alright so let's look at this hash
index thing so the point of the hash
index is if we have a series key right
and we hash it to a bucket right so here
say this is our hash table and we have
position 0 1 2 3 and what is that those
positions are locations in the file byte
offsets right so say we have this series
key right here and we hash it using
whatever hashing algorithm you like and
we say up that that maps to a bucket 1
so we see that's at 2:34 so we jump to
that spot in the file and then we say
okay there's the length of the series
key and then we can look and see if the
key is actually the same so that would
be a lookup to see like do we have this
in this file right uh so the technique
that we used and this one this one is
really interesting I'd never heard about
this technique up until like last fall
or summer it's called Robin Hood hashing
so it's been around for a while but I
have some advantages to it that actually
fit our use case really really well you
can fully load a table you don't have to
so normally with a hash table right like
you you don't you want to have extra
space so you don't have a bunch of
collisions because if you have hash
collisions then it gets more expensive
to do lookups right so we don't have to
keep linked list for lookups and with
Robinhood hashing it's actually really
good if you're doing read-only hashes
like I said our psi files are immutable
we write them once and then they get
read a bunch of times so once we compute
this hash index we never have to write
it again so we don't have to worry about
updates or inserts we don't have to
worry about deletes which means the cost
of computing it is amortized over time
so I'm going to jump through and look
like look at Robin Hood hashing kind of
try to explain it so hopefully it's
understandable so at the top we have you
know the positions in the hash table the
middle section will be the keys the keys
that we're looking up and the last one
is what we call probes which I'll
explain now for this example I'm just
going to use single character keys so
that it fits nicely on the slide and
everything looks good so first where
we're going to insert a into the hash
table we do the hash and a comes up with
position 0 we look nothing's there so
we'll put a there ok now we're going to
do B be hashes to position
one luckily enough there's nothing there
so we put be there now we're going to
insert T C hashes to position one and we
look and B is already there so the next
thing we do since we since we can't put
it there is we actually look at the
probe length of B which we see is zero
but at this point C's probe length is
zero so what the probe length is is the
number of hops you would need to make
forward in the hash table to find that
element to find that key so because
they're both the same we say we're going
to skip to the next location look it up
and since there's nothing there we put C
there and we mark it down as a probe
length of one so we have that for
bookkeeping later now we'll throw away
the probe length array after we've
computed the thing and written it out to
disk but we need it while we're
constructing the hash table okay so the
next one is we're going to try to insert
D it hashes to position one we say oh no
we can't do it because a it's already
there so we move over to the next
position B is already there but at this
point we've tracked the D has a probe
length of 1 and B has a probe length of
0 so we kick be out of position and we
put D there
and we mark its probe length is 1 and
then we look to see if we can insert B
in the next position over nope it's full
C's there but C has a probe length of 1
also so we just have to go to the next
spot over to look for g-spot it's
available we see it's there so we put be
there and we mark the probe length of 2
so this kind of moving things around
this gets to what why it's named robin
hood hashing you rob from the probe rich
and you give to the probe poor right /
where probe riches as close to zero as
possible which is counterintuitive so
another so basically what you can see
here is like when you do lookups on it
you jump to the next positions
so there's a refinement that you can
make for the lookups so when you write
this hash table one you need to write
you know the the table itself which is
that Keys table in our case we store
bite positions in the file of where to
look up the key but you need to store
that and then you need to store the
maxpro blanks everything else can get
thrown away but one other thing you can
do is you can actually look at the
average Pro blanks and store that too so
in our case we're just going to say
ignore position for say that isn't there
we're just going to say the average
probe length is 1 so what that means is
when we have a lookup later on we do the
hash to find its position and then we
add the average to it so in this case D
hashes to 0 we add 1 to it and we end up
finding the exact thing on the first hit
without having to move the probe at all
and essentially what you end up doing is
if you look it up and you add at it and
you have a miss you move the probe back
and forth between the right and left
side until you get to a position where
you either have a miss or you found the
element so here's what a cache miss
looks like so say we're trying to look
up Z to see if it exists in the file Z
hashes to zero and we see okay well a is
not Z so if that's not it so we move the
probe and we say well D is not Z so
that's not it
and notice we're tracking where we are
on the probe length for for Z so we move
the probe again and see is not Z and
where I probe length 2 now and at this
point we know we can exit because we've
stored the max probe length we know
nothing in the table has a probe length
more than 2 so we know it's a cache miss
ok so the last section I just want to
talk about a little bit is a cardinality
estimation so we estimate estimate the
cardinality of how many unique
series there are in a file in the index
how many measurements there are and how
many values there are for a given tag
key which is use useful data for our
internal telemetry and we'll be adding
stuff to the query language later to
actually expose this information to do
things to do like all sorts of different
stuff so we keep sketches basically we
use Hyper log log plus plus which is
basically some improvements on the old
hll algorithm but not going to cover
those in this talk so but we'll have
more details in a more detailed write-up
about this coming soon it's in the
nightly build for 1.3 right now it's a
feature that you can turn or the
indexing stuff so it's a feature that
you can turn on with a flag in the
config I should wrote a blog post about
it a couple of weeks ago so it's listed
in there it tells you how to do it so
that is my talk thank you thank you Paul
so now we're going to have questions
thank you very much all thanks for the
great talk I had a question so almost a
decade ago I'd use a tool called rrd so
is the influx DV have capabilities to
roll out to do roll-ups essentially you
know like rrdtool does they are like
aggregate yeah these buy hours or
minutes and days yeah so we have feature
called continuous queries which will let
you basically you can have different
retention policies in the database
retention policy sets how long you want
to keep the data around you can keep it
around forever or you can say I would
you know I want to keep this
high-precision data around for seven
days and this medium precision data
around for three months and the database
will automatically handle evicting it
for you and like I said because of the
way we organize the data on disk it's
really just dropping files so it's not
like a rewriting indexes and also crazy
stuff
so continuous queries is one way to get
that we have another project called
capacitor which is basically a
processing engine for influx flavored
time series data and you can do
aggregations and down sampling and that
kind of stuff using capacitor it's a bit
more powerful than our continuous query
language so yeah you can do that I think
about our D that makes it a bit
different is our D is a round-robin
database so it actually only works for
samples at fixed intervals of time
it also doesn't give you compression
right because round-robin databases are
just like we have we know we want we
have samples that we're taking once
every minute and we want to keep two
days worth of samples so it's just
allocates a file of that size and like
you know rotating buffer so got it
thanks
hi I took questions is it written and go
yes oh yeah sorry the database is
written in go okay okay and the
secondary question is I tried to use the
job of the Scala client maybe about 2 or
3 months ago and it didn't work yeah
that's because we can actually we
actually haven't written any of the
clients we actually just kind of kicked
it over the community so because I
should probably get into it fix it up
form yeah yeah at this point at this
stage all the client libraries or
community contributed we will take over
ownership at some point but it just
hasn't been a priority what with
everything else basically so if you have
VC money you want to give it to us we'll
hire client I have it I have I have my
own money I want to use your DB for so
maybe that's a different conversation
next question I just said I think I know
where there's a client to kind of walk
away in flux PPI run it in Scala so I
can tell you yeah I definitely know we
have Scala users I'm just not sure I'm
sure if you do a search there probably
multiple libraries it's coming from this
links that example my question is a so
the influx TV is a real-time database
what kind of data is a usually store I
mean you're monitoring that data
you know sensor data that's fine do you
how that compared to other real-time
databases for example fluid type is a
real-time OLAP databases so it's there
compared to two type of databases in
that there's do you what's the best
practice is what kind of data you store
there do you favor
OLAP data or any data or you know try to
get a sense of which points should be
used for what I mean so are two primary
use cases are monitoring data so you're
talking about server metrics application
performance monitoring data and sensor
data so those are you know generally
you're doing computations on them like
histograms percentile min mackney and
all that kind of stuff
standard deviation so we're optimize for
that you can store like real time
real like user analytics data in our
database as well but druid for example
was built originally Metamarkets which
does like behavioral analytics for
advert ad tech companies so it's a very
its foundation is very very different
like it's more like counting events and
slicing and dicing on whatever
dimensions you want to slice and dice
those on so druid will absolutely be in
flux in any sort of bake-off if that's
what you're doing because that's what it
was designed for originally so Ivan it's
been a while since I looked at the
project so it was certainly like before
the company that got started around
druid was founded so I'm sure they've
actually done a lot more since that time
but the other ones we get compared to
our graphite which is a round robin
database so it doesn't work for
event-driven data whereas our goal was
we wanted it we want influx to work for
regular and irregular time series so a
regular series of samples at fixed
intervals but an irregular one is
largely event-driven
so events could be requests to an API
they could be pageviews they could be
trades in a stock market or quotes so
general our use cases are our biggest
one is monitoring followed by kind of
real-time analytics or sensor data and
then there's a small group of people
using it for financial market data so
yeah so at one point I think you showed
your like series range blocks
mm-hm and you mentioned compression
techniques at deltas but you just
mentioned also like you can have a
regular so you basically can get events
out of time out of order because that
time is not you don't write client so
it's not determined by you what you
could get stuff like way out of order
like way delayed as well right like yes
a time could let's say you got some data
reported to you an hour late what do you
do with that because you've already
flushed to disk
you've already is it when you compact
things that you find stuff out of order
and we yeah well so if we get it depends
on
what the out of order data looks like
right so they're use cases what we see
in sensor gate most the time when we get
delayed data collection we see it in
sensor data use cases like we have one
customer who has their instrumenting
solar panels in Africa and they can only
communicate via just gsm network so they
only connect transmit data once every
four hours they just like get a package
of it and send it up but even then like
they have different collection intervals
for all these but these are individual
time series that are delayed so the data
for a specific series is still generally
written in order it's just that for the
different time series it could be out of
order
so although we have queries where you
can merge all that data together so
basically if out of order data comes in
we write it to the in memory index in
the wall later they'll get flushed to a
TSM file right and a query time we will
sort that dynamically right so what that
means is you take a hit on performance a
query time if we end up having to do
that but if we don't then you're good
and then later when the compaction runs
it will MIT will compact that older file
into the other files into new files with
the older files right so they make sure
that it's all in order right okay so
that was a point you you do have to
inspect at least every file maybe not
read the whole file but inspect the
files of the files are sorted and then
you could see if certain series are
showing up for the same real key for the
same keys and yeah so in the in present
you have to in the index in the file we
have the min time in the max time in the
file and we have them in time in the max
time for each series so when the
compaction is running the series keys in
the index are all in sorted order so we
look at them and we can merge them at
that time and then yeah we know the
minute max time so we know which ones to
decode and one last question do you
canonicalize the keys yourself because
let's say yeah I thought CPU host yeah
we do that okay yes yeah we oh the way
we do it is we keep the tags in sorted
order right by by key and then value so
the the optimal way to write data in is
to
already sorted because if you don't we
end up sorting it before we write it
actually to the to the wall